this is all about Susie Diaz it's Susie
Diaz this party Susie Diaz is running
the show I'm just gonna show up if she's
need to bring beer or something up one
oh dude oh my god a woman just fainted
I'm gonna have to call you back
[Music]
now on one what is your emergency yes
yeah I'm on the corner of Fifth and
metropolitan and across this woman it's
just just passed out on the sidewalk
here okay and is she responsive sir
[Music]
if she responsive
[Music]
no star if you can hear me she's not
responsible it's just beautiful
that is not relevant to this emergency
sir an ambulance is on its way in the
meantime I need you to check her pulse
to check her pulse white checker pull
[Music]
if she does but your skin is so soft
she's not going to make up
she's the kind of girl that just doesn't
need something you can see that she put
a lot of thought into her outfit but
that was just trying too hard she's
perfect
for me I remind you that you have not
spoken a word to this woman I need you
to see if she's breathing
[Music]
fur I need you to stay on track
okay she's not breathing look my life is
not breathing do you know how to give
mouth-to-mouth resuscitation yes I do
okay I need you to administer that now
okay
[Music]
I have to be respectful for her far this
is the only time it's okay to put your
mouth on an unconscious woman do it I
just didn't picture it happening this
way I feel like when you find the
[Music]
nine-one-one what is your emergency
there's an attractive confident
well-to-do black Manny right here on the
street
okay ma'am listen very carefully I'm
going to need you to marry him okay
shouldn't I give you Mike not to know
first yeah girl get your song
you